(Applaudissement, cris de joie et violon)
Ça fait toujours un moment ou ça part en vrille dans les mariages donc moi j'ai qu'une hâte
c'est de voir la mariée en train de pleurer/de hurler sur ses invités .
Ah c'est ton premier mariage ?
Ouai.
Parce que dans la vie s'est pas comme dans les films.
C'est vraiment plutôt bien chiant.
Oh la y'a que des vieux.
Ah ben tiens d'ailleurs il est où mon mec là ?
Je crois que j'ai retrouvé les plus belles femmes de la soirée.
Oh non.
T'es magnifique,wouah.
Merci !
Mais tu me donnes trop envie.
C'est vrai ?
Je te jure.
J'y pensé pas mais la.
J'suis amoureux,je vais larguer Matthieu maintenant,aujourd'hui je demande Laurie en mariage.
Quoi ? Tu vas larguer ?  Tu vas la demander en mariage ?
Être adulte c'est aussi savoir prendre une décision.
Bon on est nul là.
On est même pas capable d'aller parler à quelqu'un.
Bon faut que j'aille la voir maintenant là.
Vas-y.
Ben non c'est sur je peux pas.Mais si si va y.
J'vais me prendre énorme râteau
Mais pas du tout mais non essaye vas lui parler
Ok la j'y vais la j'y vais.
Maintenant Norman. Ok.
Bon ben moi j'attend que le mariage parte en vrille comme ça je profite de l'engueulade générale et hop je le largue.
Bonjour
Bonjourrrrrrrrrrrrrr
Mémé Rose je te présente mon copain.
Assis toi.
Et il s’appelle comment ce charmant jeune homme ?
Je..Je ..Je m'appelle Norman.Voilà.
Ah et vous êtes le petit ami de ma petite-fille ?
Ah ouai je suis le petit copain de de ?
Marine
Ça c'est une belle demande en mariage,regarde avec la bague et le couché de soleil.
Ah c'est canon,une demande en mariage avec un
Tu veux me demander en mariage ?  Laurie ?
De ? Je vais vous laisser.
Je croyais que tu voulais pas te marier ?
Je voulais te faire la surprise,je voulais faire une demande super romantique et voilà c'est loupé.J'suis désolé.
Mais non c'est pas raté viens.
Donc voilà tu vois je suis posé en couple comme tu voulais.
On s'aime,on s'aime tellement c'est clairement la femme de ma vie j'y pense.
Bon y'a des haut y'a des bas.
Il plaisante,il plaisante.
Bon on va peut être se marier un jour qui s'est ? Peut être.
Peut être pas peut être que oui peut être que non .
Bon ben c'est bon tu peux aller rejoindre tes potes.Elle dort.
Merci d'avoir joué le jeu jusqu'au bout c'est vraiment sympa.
Je comprends qui a envie de venir à un mariage tout seul c'est super chiant.
Moi tu sais je m'en fou je suis très bien toute seule.Mais bon ça rassure les vieux alors.
Ah euh je file j'ai mon plan cul qui m'attend.
Ah ton plan cul ? Euh...
Ben moi c'est pareil j'ai aussi un plan cul euh j'en ai même 2...3 je..
Ben profite bien.
Salut
Tchao
C'est joli par ici. Ouai.
Voilà c'est parfait là.
Ben vas y.
De quoi ? Ben...
Ah oui oui oui t'as raison.
C'est très bien ici. Ok ça marche.
Laurie ?
Ils l'ont déplacé ou quoi le bar la ? Mais tu la fais depuis tout à l'heure cette blague.
Est que tu veux me ? Allo tu m'entends ? Allo ?
Allo Allo ? Ça captes là-bas monsieur.
Ah ? Là-bas ? D'accord merci Monsieur.
En faite Laurie...
J'en ai pas envie.
En faites moi non plus.
YEEEES !!!
Nathalie ? Je peux tout t'expliquer.
T'es en train de me tromper la ?
Ça veut dire qu'on est plus ensemble ?
Je te présente Françoise.
Voilà c'est pas juste un plan cul.
Je l'aime et ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on se voit en secret.
Ah ben si ça fait plusieurs mois l'amour est le plus fort.
Ça va ?
Moi je t'aime et c'est le plus important ?
Ouai non mais moi aussi je t'aime et puis on a pas besoin de prouver aux autres qu'on est un vrai couple.
On le sait ? Ouai on le sait voilà on peut faire pleins d'autres trucs.
On peut voyager,on peut habiter ensemble.
Hein ?
Nan je dis ça.. nan mais t'inquiète on verra ça plus tard.
J'aimerai bien.
Oui ta raison on verra ça plus tard.
Moi aussi.
Eh ! Je suis célibataire.
Qui veux me rouler une pelle ?
C'est bon la oh ?
J'suis pas un boudin.
Moi ?
Allez.
Et la célib.
Oh ça va.
Ah ben non attend quand même.
C'est un truc de fou.
Depuis le temps.
Et c'est quoi ça ? Vous êtes fiancé ou quoi ?
Euh.. Non j'ai dit non.
Oui moi aussi.
Oui mais elle le met quand même parce que ça coûte une blinde ce truc.
Et vous avez raison on peut faire ce qu'on veut qu'on fasse.
Et pas ce qu'on veut ce que les gens veulent qu'on fasse.
Non mais ça veut rien dire.
J'crois il est un peu tard pour les phrases philosophiques.
C'est pas du tout ça .
Tu te fous de ma gueule ?
Tu fais tout pour faire foirer mon mariage.
On avait dit que c'était mon moment.
Mais MERDE euh.
Ah ben voilà ça est.
Mais reviens.
Et c'était un super mariage on trinque ?
Allez oui allez.
Oui Grand Corps Malade.
Oh Marie ! Allez.
Euh... Je réponds quoi ?